hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
forget-me-nots enemy okay enemy I don't
know
yeah I see okay so some of you guys told
me that I could telecon eyes the bear
Henry whatever his name was
blue blue blue hi
pick him up I can scoot him out put him
on that plum can put them on that plunk
I can put him on that plunk there we go
aha it means that damn it I probably
shouldn't have dropped down here yeah
they dress up now Herbert dirt ball so
that what doc what that wait a minute
there we go so I think I just make this
epic leaf not bye Nana okay all right I
know I know I know I know I know I
screwed up but let's see oh and also
seems like all the achievements are
resetting but that's okay you hey dick
Herbert Herbert Wow
you're open pick you up shove you in
I said shove you in okay well if I shove
you there what's with that
what is that anyway she named it rose
just like the flower she played with it
every day
then one day she just got tired of it
I'll never get tired of Howard you say
that now but one day you'll grow too big
for how big AHA right right okay so that
mannequin I'm thing is apparently the
doll of another little girl in the Tahoe
hello hey how's it going
alright so I got this nail it oh hi how
what has like portal the horror Edition
you having fun playing with me yeah okay
alright then have this where does this
go man this is like I had no idea that
this game was like this but I've never
seen a puzzle platformer like this with
horror elements yeah kind of creepy well
bats flying around anyway anyway I can't
really see what's where this is going
unless one of those oh hello
she use interact F swap hand right under
go hot bear I know
hi okay so I got this box here but I
don't think I'm supposed to take that
with me this might have to go down Henry
go down to buy you liked it okay now ah
whoa hello
those aren't mannequins those are actual
body parts aren't they oh hello hi yes
looking back on it all you asked me so
one case one case you just cut out of
your mind some grace of God just purge
it from your memory without hesitation I
would say this mmm
let alone the scene itself the gruesome
body left behind more than anything that
little girl is in this little girl this
is up a big baby girl ah I don't know I
have no idea really
okay so there's something written up
there you don't need you don't need ball
you don't need ball
you don't need bear I need bear I don't
know this bear doesn't seem that useful
get in the rack bear this is a
legitimate torture chamber by the way
just I'm seeing here okay so there's
something in there maybe I need to get
oh oh oh okay all right all right hon
hold on I got this yeah I keep expecting
portal music to play every time I go on
one of those how did you downtown okay
so if that I gotta find a way to get in
that box cuz there are two buttons to
press one for the box and one for the
other thing I don't know how to get up
farther I can't tell can eyes anything
over here will keep squeaking what's
with this squeaky I'm not sure okay I'm
um kinda have a loss don't cut
ah okay I'm gonna act like that never
happened a birdie birdie birdie burger
ah I got that I totally got that and
wasn't wandering around for about 10
hours I totally got that like right away
stay quiet hey bear I don't think you're
out for my best interests here I don't
think you're out to do anyone any good
come here boob does it tell me you ready
sweetheart I got this book okay mommy
are you well dear haha of course every
Teddy needs a name can't use it
Howard Howard yay there we go okay what
did it all we turned it oh okay you
Boosh
yeah oh that was a torch in the wall all
in all it was just another torch in the
wall okay so I got in is this another
thingy yeah it's another thingy another
power device so I use this one
the totally obvious places that are
placed right here totally obvious
noobish right now I turn it the other
way what got oh that's probably not a
good sign
mmm
slightly demonic Wow
oh oh oh hi hi ah ooh this cross kind of
fell in Crusty's bodies I guess they're
dead so it doesn't matter um how does uh
oh I know what I need to trap Henry in
there because I need to take this one
out no no that's not it ah okay
uh uh uh uh uh uh okay that did that did
that
what those down all those down you dick
goes down that was there bhag bhag ooh
haha [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ha ha ha oh Henry just tap-danced in
here for a bit
my target ah ha ha toot ah damn it what
the hell I'm sorry I called you out on
your stupid bug Yamma Yamma okay I'll be
back and then in a few seconds
nah okay we're back alright so I got
back to the part by warping through time
like I do so well now let's hope that it
does not bug oh wow oh yeah nailed it oh
I'm the best I'm the best I like it when
a game gets emotional and gets all upset
when I call it bad things for its bugs
bugs also that weird screeching in my
ears
hello-o
ah I fell down I fell down go boom
I fell down go boom okay
oh hi hi there doctor
alright it's okay is it don't you
understand I'm trying to help Mar you
why are you hurting me Manny I don't
know what you mean
I've been here waiting for you you're
imagining things again keeps me safe you
can't hurt me anymore
let go of Howard and Howard can't
protect you he just wants to keep us
apart yeah that's it he just knows the
last thing I want to do is to hurt you
Annie
but I can't let you hurt yourself either
or anyone else ever again me Howard just
plain we have fun this is very serious
at right you are in danger I can't
protect you much longer it's not all up
to me when has he ever protected uh-huh
yes right right
I protect ya you you he tries to keep
Muslim hey guys
an arch y'all still a chance
into anything morphing
am I gonna get a choice here am i it's
gonna all come down to me it's all gonna
come down to me is it all gonna come
down to me look I'm not okay so uh yeah
this is weird
I can't hear you couldn't hear any of
that something about something loves me
Henry love you holy crap
oh oh oh I can't see anything
okay so obviously this goes in here yay
oh I see oh oh oh that's nice oh that's
lovely
yes absolutely um darling yes Wow
okie dokie let's get um let's get a move
on here what that was that three pots of
blue white flowers anybody died no idea
I have no idea I'm out of here I'm out
of here I'm out of here I'm out of here
Oh oh that that that that that's
probably not good I don't know how to
throw myself just being honest
hi hi can you uh aha nailed it okay I
gotta get you all the way over there
go dammit Henry alright not
I'm coming Henrik ha Oh No
all right take wha
ruk me what what the hell Wow
I know that was a shock stick with me
then we can leave the scary parts behind
but I'd encourage any did that happen
before did it did it do something weird
or did what the hell happened there was
this first I was hurt because we used to
be such swell friends and all but then I
got to meet her new friend I didn't like
him at all what is going on I'm so
confused
I'm so confused I thought I respawn back
in the other area I thought I'm grandma
phone what am i doing what am i doing
ha oh god I just had a flashback damn
needed that sounded like the monster
chase noise and I'm like go was about to
sprint off the edge huh I swear good god
this game is massive are they
hardtack here ok so what do I do I can't
get across here doesn't really help me
maybe there's something I need to build
a bridge or something I don't know
I don't like this game
he gave me freaky oh hello here no
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
who what it is kite
I remember Annie she and I used to have
swell time stick as well huh birthday
party and everything like that but when
I stopped seeing her around I just
assumed she made a new best friend
oh okay alright um so yeah I don't
really
oh hello what got what Kyle likes oh um
I'm from I'm Way over time here or I may
not be I don't know I don't know where I
don't know where I am exactly but um I'm
just gonna end it here cuz I'm let's
free me the hell out and I don't really
know what to do and I don't feel like
waiting around for ten minutes trying to
find out what I need to do so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos adapt done
and as always we'll see you in that
video bye
my god
hi